With non-patterning knitting machines
and anytime you want to work a hand
manipulated stitch pattern, there's
usually a lot of counting of needles
involved.
For simple stitch transfers, you can use
a pencil or a water soluble pen and simply
Mark the needle bed.
You could also use your needle
pushers to select sets of needles.
I've found that cheat sheets come in handy
for more complicated stitch patterns.
We've created a set of sheets for
the various gauges of machines.
The grids are sized according
to the needle pitch.
That's the space between
the centers of the needles.
Here.
I'm using a 6.5 millimeter gauge and the
needles of my LK-150 fit exactly in the
boxes of the grid.
I've marked my stitch
pattern sequence in pink.
I'll have two needles that will be small
cables over three rows, and there will be
six needles in between that are
going to remain in plain knitting.
As I'm knitting, I just simply line up the
appropriate row on the cheat sheet with my
needle bed.
Pull out the needles
according to the chart.
I moved the cheat sheet along the bed
for the width of my knitting and without
having to count needles, I'm now
ready to do the hand manipulation.
These are fun little cables that add
a bit of texture to your knitting.
Both the knit and the
purl side is interesting.
Making this all over pattern, a
good choice for blankets and scarfs.
I'm releasing the first
stitch down three rows.
There will be three strands to relatch.
I'll latch 2 of the strands and then drop
the latch tool, keeping the stitch in the
hook.
Using a second lanch tool.
I'll drop the next stitch down.
Again.
There's going to be three strands to latch
and a latch up all three and place this
stitch on the right hand needle.
This is the first half of our mini cable.
Now pick up the first latch tool again,
latch that last strand and hang the stitch
on the left hand needle.
You've reformed two stitches over three
rows and you created a cable on the second
row without having to count any stitches.
Okay.
Another quick way of adding texture to
your knitting is to reform columns of
stitches.
You can create ribbing this way, but
sometimes a bit of texture on a reverse
stockinette background is just
what you want for your garment.
Traditionally, we knit a section of our
garment and drop a stitch reforming every
row or every other row for texture.
I've often noticed that my stitches
are uneven and look sloppy.
Try this.
Knit your piece with a needle out of
work then reform the column of strands.
It saves a bit of time because
you don't have to drop the stitch.
The resulting re-latched
stitches are tighter.
And keep in mind that this will impact
your garment stitch gauge a bit.
Here.
You can see both methods.
On the left is the reformed drop stitch.
After blocking this woolyarn, the
sloppiness is gone and the stitch sits up
really nice and high against
that purl background.
Giving great texture on the right is
the reformed needle out of work stitch.
It lays flatter against the purl side
and it is slightly faster to work.
Best tip for faster hand manipulation
is having extra tools available.
This saves you a ton of time.
You notice that I use two latch
tools when working the mini cables.
There are multi-pronged transfer tools,
short garter bar sections, adjustable
transfer tools.
All of these things come in handy
when working manipulated stitches.
Thank you for watching this tutorial.
The complete set of cheat sheets
for all machine gauges is available.